hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today's dead stream was packed
full loaded with season 3 information
with a lot more coming next week so it's
I'm wasting time to get right into this
so first up the newest weekly content is
the new emotes of which of the sports
emotes which I talked about a couple
weeks ago as long as as well as new
executions percent area and shinobi
which I'll show to you right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
so those were dope I don't really know
what the price range of these are but
you can obviously check that when you
get in game we're moving on though the
newest event is announced and it's going
to be a call to realistic elimination
which is the same as the realistic
Dominion we received but just an
elimination game modes next up the new
heroes were confirmed to be the
Highlander and gladiator and I will show
them their teaser videos for you right
now as well
[Music]
[Music]
so those are the videos those looked
super badass I'll have those playing in
the background while we talk about this
but season 3 will be starting on August
15th for four for season pass owners
they can obviously pick up these
characters at that time and then August
22nd for non season pass owners to pick
those characters up regarding the
characters Highlander was described as a
big strong counter attacker who would
also be a hybrid class he's also going
to be wielding the heaviest sword in the
game the claim were so they're probably
very slow heavy attacks but very high
damaging lot see how he plays out and
then for the gladiator he's going to be
equipped with a trident and a small
shield as opposed to the net as
everybody thought he was going to be
equipped with and he's the knight
assassin class I don't really see why
but alright but he can also stun
opponents with superfast attacks and big
stamina pool or he has a big stamina
pool and reduced cooldowns on feats
compared to other characters so I don't
know how I really feel about the
gladiator he might be a bit overpowered
but once again the characters aren't
even out yet we'll have to see what
happens at that point I'll be making
tons of videos on these guys when they
do come out though so don't be worried
about that and then they also mentioned
the new maps the two new maps are going
to be Sentinel and the Viking village
each equipped with their own type of
trap the ballista and a rolling ball of
death which spikes yeah it sounds pretty
badass just from saying it but in season
3 the level of gear will also be a lot
easier by using less Salvage and steel
to rank up your gear in the lower ranks
like with grey and blue gear and then
requiring more steel and salvage to
higher up to rank up the higher rank
such as the legendary gear that's coming
in season 3 and then the current epic
gear that we have right now it's
basically a way to get players to
actually spend their salvage for once
because I know tons of us have Salvage
saves up that we never really use
there's going to be tons and tons of
info on these characters such as
executions emotes movesets all that jazz
that they did lat with the last season
but that's going to be in next week's
episode so once again stay tuned right
here so I can give you guys all that
juicy information next week next up
though the season will also come with
ranked mode and tons
new gear as well as UI changes like
changing the hero menus for executions
and emotes and removing certain traps on
ledges on certain maps and making maps
bigger these ledges will be removed from
the maps overwash forest and tower ruin
but only indoor mental and elimination
they might also come to the other maps
but these were the three most talked
about so they're going to do those first
as well for season three the chip damage
changes and The Revenge changes will be
in the start of season three I guess the
community really did enjoy those what
they were saying so they're going to be
adding those also a nerf to all melee
attacks such as shove leg sweep and
Centurions jab and all the other ones
like warlords charge and Raiders charge
and such may it's going to be making it
a lot easier to survive if you're
attacked by multiple censor Valks for
this example by not being affected by
the second animation while in the middle
of the first one so if once again that's
just making you a lot easier to you know
not die immediately from a two-man gank
of a Centurion group next up was the
faction war and regarding the faction
war even though no one really cares
about it they're going to be adding more
territories once again but the ability
to place a war banner now what the war
banner does is that which now every time
you earn war assets they will
automatically be placed at that war
banner instead of placing them every
single game now I'm assuming you're
going to have to you know keep replacing
the war banner after every turn but once
again it's better than doing every game
so I do like this change very excited
for this this season will also include a
duel tournament for ranked as well as
the anti runaway mechanic which we
talked about which basically is slowing
the player down that runs away from the
fight allowing the other player to catch
up now there was tons and tons of more
patch notes to talk about but the
deficit there roughly 22 pages long when
they release it and they're not going to
talk for two hours just about patch
notes so they're going to put them on
the website
once those go live I'll look at the
changes and if it's worth making a video
on you'll be seeing a video probably
later tonight it probably takes a while
to you know type out and such but anyway
that's going to be the end of the video
hopefully you guys did enjoy let me know
what you guys think about these new
characters in the map so I think I
really talked about this video if you
did enjoy though leave a like dislike it
if you didn't and subscribe for more
foreigner content season 3 is starting
soon so I do plan on doing guides for
all these characters and then
other videos for them so stay tuned for
that but anyway I hope we all did enjoy
and if these patch notes come out then I
will see you tonight for the next video
good bye guys